et maintenant donc on va faire comme si
l'âme d'ophélie winter était entré dans
votre corps maria pacôme
imaginez un moment où je payais habités
comme ça je fais lilas vous êtes au celi
interview dans la peau d'ophélie
ferrer qu'on vous appelle ophélie ou
afellay afellay ophélie ophélie vous
êtes toujours très très très sexy c'est
quoi votre votre secret j'ai pas de
secret je suis né comme ça avec cette
séduction extraordinaire c'était plus de
féminité et ce talent à tout cas fait
j'y peux rien c'est comme ça c'est la
vie
ophélie vous vous trouvez commandant
mauvais esprit superbe
un geste que faire quand même parce que
être odieuse comme ça et rester quand
même belle élégante et faut le faire
jésus fait au fait d'y aller comme maria
pacôme dans le film elle pas mal maria
pacôme l'a bien supporté la canicule
océans et chats ouais non non non non
un peu mieux je le vis maria pacôme
décidément j'aurais été arrangé par les
plus grandes
cet énorme arrêt et le théâtre ophélie
vous y pensez j'hésite le savoir le
moment je continue la chanson c'est
quand même ce que je préfère et vos
projets dans les années qui viennent
c'est quoi vous achetez un jean taille
basse
je ne sais pas vous c'est de vous poser
une question
pour le moment je vis au jour le jour je
pense que là je vais très apprécié dans
ce que je viens de faire enfin j'ai
prouvé chez une comédienne jusqu'ici
c'était tu étais pas on avait été assez
dur avec moi je pense que là on va voir
que je suis
ophélie est ce que vous pouvez me
chantait un petit bout de comment tout
le monde le fait mais non je connais pas
ce truc là tout le monde le fait
entassés sur la masturbation féminine et
là je ne sais pas voilà voilà
oui
un marathon